the story of Thanksgiving you and I
we're taught in elementary school is
that the very lisa disney v version and
it's not the first time we've been duped
about indigenous people's place in US
history
I'm looking at you Pocahontas here's a
list of things not at the first
Thanksgiving turkey pumpkin pie mashed
potatoes and your extended family's
angst what many of us know about
Thanksgiving is incredibly inaccurate
there's a romanticized version of
Thanksgiving children are dressing up as
so-called
Indians they don't even know what tribe
is involved they have no idea who we are
what our history has been so how did
history transform the tale of indigenous
people and pilgrims into a harmonious
coming together with a feel-good story
sneak-peek the Civil War mary had a
little lamb' play a big role and how
does our telling and retelling and
teaching up Thanksgiving affect the
nation's dialogue about indigenous
people and the issues they face
Thanksgiving celebrated into u.s. is
this American myth but it is really an
eraser of the history of indigenous
peoples hey Pam I mean I am this is a J
plus and this Sunday we're exploring the
real story of Thanksgiving why we learn
about it the way we do and how it
impacts all of us so get ready to gorge
on a plate full of facts
let's get into this cornucopia of
knowledge shall we so many of us were
taught the Pilgrims and the Native
American shared a meal in 1621 to
celebrate the new settlers good harvests
come on you remember
Plymouth Rock the Mayflower lots of feel
good vibes etc etc etc like this
Schoolhouse Rock jingle taught a
generation of kids and someone said
we're there it may not look home at this
point
well the truth sounds more like a story
from an on-duty neighborhood watch
captain the wampa knock was to try but
what we call the first Thanksgiving and
I'll let tribal member Ramona Peters
explain what really went down there's a
lot of things they finally got a good
crop and they had a celebration in which
I known to us they celebrated by
shooting off guns we didn't know who
they were shooting at Peter says the
indigenous people and settlers stayed
together for a few days because back
then every day was a hunt for food
hashtag old-school organic and that's
what actually happened on the first
Thanksgiving
you see Native Americans and pilgrims
weren't BFFs their relationship was much
more transactional and wary they had a
treaty that basically said you watch my
back and I'll watch yours Peter says our
current collective memory of
Thanksgiving doesn't accurately reflect
how those two groups viewed each other
that trail to mingle with us they were
very afraid and their way they lived in
the way we lives were so different
we didn't play so now you're wondering
well Danny Mayan how did we get our
current idea about Thanksgiving answer
Abraham Lincoln the nation was in the
middle of a bloody battle severing it in
two when the 16th president declared the
last Thursday of November a day of
thanks in 1863 he helped the move would
unify the country I'm sure you feel that
unity every time you sit across the
table from your extended family on that
Thursday in November hmm tastes like
harmony Lincoln's proclamation came
after a woman named Sarah Josepha Hale
spent more than 30 years lobbying for
such a holiday you know sjh as the
author of mary had a little lamb go
ahead and bank that little tidbit for an
upcoming trivia night you're welcome
Peter says she considers the act of
Thanksgiving an integral part of our
culture I think it's important
to continue I like it to stimulate
interested Native American people who
have survived and are still around enter
the indigenous people's sunrise ceremony
which used to be known as on
Thanksgiving
it's an annual gathering at the former
prison Alcatraz that began in 1975 and
morningstar galley has been attending it
since she was a young child now she
brings her children to it to honor and
remember the Native American dead it
looks very different in terms of holding
a ceremony with a dozen people versus
5,000 people but the intention is still
the same I continue to go in terms of
carrying the message and holding a
responsibility to teach my children and
to share with my children the true
history of our people the gathering is
not just about recognizing the dead it
also commemorates the 1969 to 1971
occupation of Alcatraz by Indians of all
tribes that's when a group of Native
Americans claimed it was theirs by right
of discovery today the act of
discovering things that are already
there is better known as Columbus II the
occupants wanted to buy the island for
$24 in glass beads and a red cloth the
same price the indigenous people
supposedly received for Manhattan their
goal was to transform the prison into a
school and a cultural centre for
indigenous children it never happened
but the demonstration did galvanize
Native American activists who today used
the Unthank giving as a reminder of
their continued fight for recognition
we are not extinct that we are still
here and still standing Gally says the
country needs to highlight the
historical references of natives coming
to the table being poisoned and given
blankets infested with smallpox ideally
I feel that what has been established as
a national day of mourning is a time of
reflection and a time of acknowledgement
and almost 400 years after the first
Thanksgiving Native Americans continue
to fight for recognition and respect the
people the census identifies as American
Indians and
Alaska Natives make up less than 2% of
the population and many of those people
live in poverty their median household
income of about $37,000 is around 31
percent lower than the national average
there are also environmental struggles
Native American reservations have had
industrial waste dumped in them
polluting rivers lakes and tribal lands
and there's what Peters calls their most
pressing issue is it possible one key to
understanding Native Americans plight is
to fully acknowledge and embrace the
accurate history of Thanksgiving hey
guys you just joined us for the true
story of Thanksgiving but what I really
want to talk about right now is the food
I have never eaten so many mashed
potatoes in my life don't forget to Like
share and subscribe join us next Sunday
for another awesome video please ignore
our sad sad fake turkey and let us know
in the comment section what you would
like to see us do next I'm actually
gonna eat this pumpkin pie now so see
you next week